What is it we have seen? We have started with an initial hypothesis.
>From this hypothesis we have made predictions. We have made experiments.
We checked with the experiments, validated the prediction.
If they did, we refined our hypothesis. If they didn't, we came up with alternate hypothesis.
We have repeated the process until we came up with a diagnosis.
That is, a theory that is consistent with our earlier observations, and that also
predicts future observations. In our case, the correct behavior.
Based on this diagnosis, how the failure came to be, we have fixed a code
accordingly, and we have seen in our additional experiments that the theory holds.
That is, the diagnosis was valid from the beginning on,
and therefore, was a correct explanation of how the failure came to be.
Note that there are many ways to come up with an initial hypothesis.
There are also many ways to refine a hypothesis and reject a hypothesis.
Note that there may be multiple hypotheses to start with,
and also of course during the scientific method, you may come up with different hypotheses.
If you have two competing hypotheses for the same failure,
what you do is set up an experiment that decides which of the hypotheses
is supported, and which of the hypotheses is rejected.
At the end, there should be only one hypothesis, there should be only one
theory, and there should be only one diagnosis on how the failure came to be.